hi it's matthew martin from details and
i just saw the gucci collection which
was very luxe and elegant the jackets
were cut a little boxy which i like
specially is a lot of them were paired
with these really slim trousers I loved
all the military detail and some of the
pieces there was a coat that was really
cropped and it had these gold buttons on
the sides which I thought was very chic
also there was a pair of navy pants that
had this really cool gold piping down
the side you know military might not be
something you're comfortable to do
however if you did it one piece on their
own imperative would say a regular Chino
or a trouser that was really simple I
think it's a really easy way to pull off
that trend I loved all the boots that
had perforated detail on the toad there
are also a bunch of really cool chunky
cardigans and you know she paired the
some of them over a blazer which I'd
never seen before and actually liked
that it was a really good way to mix a
texture and pattern in the same look
without having it feel too baggy or boxy
so I definitely would try to incorporate
that kind of look into your wardrobe for
fall/winter for more videos you can
check out details calm and please be
sure to follow me on twitter at details
map